welcome to Azure devops road map 2024
your compass to navigating the ever
evolving landscape of cloud development
and collaboration in this video we will
embark on a journey into the future of
azure devops over the next few minutes
we will unveil the Innovative strategies
tools and best practices that will shape
the way we build deploy and manage
application in the Azure ecosystem
whether you're a season devops
professional or just beginning your
Cloud development Adventure this road
map is your key to staying ahead of the
curve let's dive in and explore the
promising Horizons of azure devops in
2024 that said if these are the type of
videos you'd like to watch then hit that
subscribe button and the bell icon to
get notified and if you're a
professional with minimum one year of
experience and an aspiring devops
engineer looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simply learns postgraduate program and
devops from Caltech University in
collaboration with IBM is just what you
need for more details head straight to
our homepage and search for postgraduate
program and devops from calch University
or simply click on the link in the
description box below now without
further delay over to our training so
without further delay let's get started
by understanding the agenda for today's
session first we will learn who exactly
is an Azure devops engineer followed by
that we will look into the skills
required to become one then the roles
and responsibilities of azure devops
engineer then the most important point
of today's session which is the road map
or how to become an aure devops engineer
in 2024 next ahead we will discuss the
salary compensation offered to Azure
devops engineer
and we will wrap up the video by
discussing the top companies hiring
Azure devops engineers in 2024 and
Beyond now let's get started with the
first point that is who exactly is an
Azure devops engineer Azure devops now
known as Azure devop Services is a
cloud-based platform by Microsoft that
provides that provides a comprehensive
set of tools and services for software
development and collaboration it covers
the entire software development life
cycle offering features for planning
coding testing and deployment the key
components include Azure boards for
project planning Azure repos for source
code management Azure pipelines for
automating build and deployment process
Azure test plans for testing and equal
quality assurance and aure artifacts for
package management teams can use Azure
devops to work together efficiently
track projects progress manage a source
code automate software bills and
Implement continuous integration and
continuous deployment or also known as
cicd pipelines it promotes collaboration
between a development and operations
teams streamlines development processes
and helps organizations deliver high
quality software products more rapidly
and reliably and the professionals who
take care of all these processes are
none other than Azure devops Engineers
now moving ahead we will discuss Azure
devops Engineers skills so what EX
exactly are the skill set that you need
to become one to excel as an Azure
devops engineer you need a diverse skill
set that combines technical expertise
with collaboration and problem solving
abilities here are the top five skills
that you need to become one first one
Azure Services knowledge as an Azure
devops engineer you should have a strong
understanding of azure cloud services
and resources familiarity with services
like Azure virtual machines azure your
app service Azure functions Azure cubity
service or AKs Azure SQL database and
more are crucial for Designing and
deploying applications on aure the
second one continuous integration and
continuous deployment or cicd pipelines
Proficiency in cicd is fundamental you
should be able to design Implement and
manage cicd pipelines using aure devops
or similar tools this includes Auto
meeting builds testing and deployment
processes to ensure smooth and efficient
application delivery followed by that we
have infrastructure ascod or IAC Mastery
of IAC tools like Azure resource manager
or armm templates terraform or anible is
essential IAC enables you to Define and
manage your infrastructure in a
cloud-based automated manner ensuring
reproducibility and scalability now the
fourth one one scripting and automation
strong scripting skills especially in
Powershell and Bash are important for
managing and automating Azure resources
we should be able to create scripts to
provision configure and maintain Azure
Services efficiently now the last one
collaboration and communication
effective communication and
collaboration skills are vital for
working in cross functional teams Azure
devops Engineers of and collaborate with
developers system administrators and
other stakeholders the ability to
communicate ideas manage project tasks
and troubleshoot effectively is
essential in addition to all these
Technical and collaboration skills
continuous learning and staying up toate
with the evolving Azure ecosystem are
essential for success in this role Azure
devops Engineers must adapt to new
technologies and best practices as they
emerge in the fast space world of cloud
and devops now let us discuss the aure
devops roles and responsibilities aure
devops Engineers play a critical role in
software development process focusing on
optimizing development and deployment
workflows here are the top five
important roles and responsibilities of
an Azure devops engineer first one cicd
pipeline development create and maintain
continuous integration continuous
deployment pipelines using Azure devop
automate build test and development
processes to ensure fast and reliable
software delivery Monitor and improve
pipeline performance and efficiency next
one is infrastructure as code Implement
infrastructure as code practices to
manage and provision Azure resources and
environments use tools like Azure
resource manager templates Azure CLI or
Azure Powershell to Define
infrastructure in a code-based
controlled version controlled manner
next is conf configuration and release
management manage application
configuration and release process to
ensure smooth and controlled deployments
coordinate release schedules including
roll back plans and Implement release
strategies like blue green deployments
or Canary releases now the fourth one is
about security and compliance enhance
security by implementing secure code
practices and incorporating Securities
scanning tools in the cicd pipeline
ensure compliance with industry
regulations and standards by configuring
Azure security and compliance tools
lastly monitoring and troubleshooting
set up monitoring and logging Solutions
using Azure Monitor and application
insights to track application
performance and detect issues
troubleshoot the resolve deployment
performance and security issues in
azured environments Azure devops
Engineers need to collaborate closely
with development and operations teams
continuously improve processes and stay
up toate on Azure services and best
practices they play a pivotal role in
delivering highquality software products
efficiently and securely now let's
discuss the most important point of
today's session which is about how to
become an Azure devops engineer creating
a comprehensive Azure devops road map
requires an understanding of these
specific goals projects and Technologies
your organization is planning to
implement however this can provide a
general outline of the key areas to
consider when creating an aure devops
road map so first one is assessment and
planning evaluate the current state of
your development and operations process
identify pain points and areas for
improvement Define your organizational
goals and objectives for adopting Azure
devops the next step is tool selection
choose the Azure devops services and
tools that best align with your need
needs this may include Azure boots Azure
repos Azure pipelines Azure test plans
and Azure artifacts consider integration
with other Azure services and third
party tools now the third step is
training and skill development invest in
training and upskilling your team in
aure devops practices and Technologies
encourage certification and continuous
learning to ensure team's proficiency
the fourth step is migration and
onboarding plan and execute the
migration of existing projects and code
repositories to assure devops onboard
your team to the new platform and
educate them on best practices moving
ahead we have agile and devops practices
as the fifth step Implement agile
methodologies and devops practices to
streamline development and operations
procedure Define workflows processes and
the policies that promote collaboration
and automation sixth step is continuous
integration and continuous deployment
set up cicd pipelines using Azure
pipelines to automate the build and
deployment processes Implement testing
quality control and release management
as the part of your cicd pipeline
seventh step is monitoring and feedback
Implement monitoring and logging
solutions to track application
performance and detect issues collect
and analyze user feedback to make
continuous improvements now the eighth
step security and compliance integrate
security practices into your development
and deployment pipelines ensure
compliance with industry standards and
regulations by using Azure security and
compliance tools now the ninth step is
scalability and cost management plan for
scalability and cost optimization by
leveraging Azure resources and services
Implement cost tracking and optimization
strategies to control Cloud expenditure
now the next one is long-term strategy
develop a long-term strategy for Azure
devops adoption including future
upgrades new services and evolution of
your devops practices the 11th step is
about collaboration and communication
Foster collaboration amongst development
and operations teams through
communication channels and tools
encourage a culture of collaboration and
knowledge sharing now the 12th step is
performance metrics and KPS Define and
track key performance in indicators kpis
to measure the success and efficiency of
your Azure devops initiatives use
metrics to identify areas for
improvement now the 13th one and the
last one is feedback loop and iteration
establish a feedback loop that allows
for continuous Improvement in your Azure
devops processes iterate and adapt your
road map based on feedback and changing
organizational needs remember that your
azure devops road map should be dynamic
and adaptable to changing circumstances
regularly review and adjust your plans
to align with your organization's
evolving goals and the everchanging
technology landscape now moving ahead we
will discuss the devops engineer salary
details if you are in India and if you
are a beginner then you can expect
salaries ranging from 3 lakhs to 6 lakhs
per anim and if you're an intermediate
candidate let's say one to 2 years of
experience as a aure devops engineer
then you can expect salaries ranging
from 6 lakhs to 12 lakhs per Anon and if
you're a highly experienced candidate
with more than four years of experience
you can expect salaries ranging from 12
lakhs to 20 lakhs per anim remember
these salary figures are based on the
organization you're working with and the
experience and the job location moving
ahead we have us so if you are a
beginner as a short devops engineer and
you are in America then you can expect
salary ranging from $60,000 to $90,000
per anom if you are an intermediate
candidate let's say 1 to two years of
experience then you can expect salaries
ranging from $90,000 to $120,000 per
anim and if you're a highly experienced
candidate with more than four years of
experience and you can expect salaries
ranging from
$120,000 to $160,000 per an again these
salary numbers vary based on the company
you're working with your experience and
job location moving ahead we will
understand the companies which are
hiring Azure devops Engineers there are
a lot of companies hiring Azure devops
Engineers but the prominent players in
the industry are Microsoft Amazon web
services Google Cloud IBM Oracle Deo Del
Technologies Cisco Systems Accenture
cognizant enosis IBM and many more and
with that we have come to the end of
this session and and with that we have
reached to the end of this tutorial on
Azure devops road map for 2024 should
you need any assistance PP or any other
resources used in this session please
let us know in the comment section below
and our team of experts will be happy to
help you as soon as possible until next
time thank you for watching and keep
learning stay tuned for more from Simply
learn staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our program s and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here